ANOMIE
Le premier à avoir utilisé le concept d’anomie
est Jean-Marie Guyau en 1885.
L’anomie désigne alors l’absence de loi
fixe.
Durkheim s’approprie le concept en 1893
dans “De la division du travail social”
et lui apporte une connotation négative.
L’anomie devient alors synonyme d’anarchie,
d’absence de régulation et de loi.
Le mot est recyclé par Durkheim en 1897 dans
sa célèbre étude Le Suicide où l’anomie
devient une des causes de suicide, lorsque
les désirs d’un individu ne sont plus limités
par des normes sociales.
Le mot tombe dans l’oubli jusqu’à être
ressuscité en 1938 par Robert Merton qui
l’utilise pour désigner un décalage entre
les buts définis par une société et les
moyens dont les individus disposent pour atteindre
ces buts.
Très à la mode vers 1960, il sera par la
suite quelque peu délaissé par les sciences
sociales.
Source : Mucchielli, les 100 mots de la sociologie.